[Music]
skip Porter we can't believe it's been
almost 20 years since you first hit the
big screen Harry Potter we watched you
grow up and save the entire Wizarding
World with the help of Ron and Hermione
and now you've got your own kids at
Hogwarts the eight movies will always
have a special place in our hearts but
there are some things that we feel we're
missing and would have made the movies
even better check out these 10 Harry
Potter scenes that never should have
been cut you won't believe which scene
had Draco Malfoy doing the right thing
for once it's powerful but it's not the
same
the first scene comes from the first
movie Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone it's easy to forget that the
golden trio weren't always best friends
Ron and Harry hit it off immediately
when they sat together on the train but
they thought Hermione was obnoxious for
a while she doesn't know it all and she
thought that would make people like her
on Halloween she overheard Ron and
Salter she ran off to the bathroom to
cry and got cornered by a troll Harry
and Ron came to save her and the rest
was friendship history but after that
scene the three kids are walking down
the hallway
Harry points out that Hermione if you
hadn't insulted hope Ron says the look
on Hermione's face when he says they're
friends is priceless this scene proves
how important their friendship is to
Hermione we would have loved to see this
in the final cut Harry Potter and the
Chamber of Secrets had a lot going on
that didn't make it into the movie the
main issue of course is that the Chamber
of Secrets has been opened there's a
monster that has been released and is
attacking kids the heir of Slytherin
opened the chamber but no one knows who
it is in the books most of the school
thinks Harry's behind it he is shunned
for most of the story
this is downplayed in the movie for the
sake of time but this deleted scene
would have shown exactly how hurt and
only Harry was he overhears a group of
hufflepuffs gossiping about him one of
their own Justin Finch fleshly has been
attacked ernie Macmillan is trying to
convince Hannah Abbott that Harry is the
heir and that he hates muggle-borns he
can't help it that he is a parcel mouth
he's just trying to do the right thing
of course the real heir of Slytherin is
Tom Riddle aka Voldemort a lot of the
clues and explanations were cut in
Chamber of Secrets one scene was
important to Harry figuring out who the
hair of southern was Ron and Harry are
visiting Hermione in the hospital wing
she is looking at the diary and says
there's a name in there Tom Marvolo
riddle Ron recognizes the name when he
had to tension polishing the trophy room
he remembered seeing the name on a
trophy Tom Riddle had received an award
for services to the school fifty years
before her minor members I told you the
last time the chamber was open they are
able to figure out that this tom riddle
guy is behind it of course once Harry
meets the ghost of Tom Riddle he learned
who he really is that was Lord
Voldemort's real name it would have
helped set up the clues a lot better Ron
Weasley is such a great character but
the fandom sometimes gives him a hard
time there are times that Ron can be a
little dim in oblivious but he's a great
friend to Harry in Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban there's a cutscene
that proves this Harry wasn't allowed to
go to Hogsmeade because his Guardians
wouldn't sign the permission slip he's
also being stalked by Sirius Black who
he doesn't know is a good guy yet when
Ron and Hermione get back from their
first Hogsmeade trip they tell him all
about it
Hermione first notices that Harry is
really sad listening to him she tries to
say it was boring Ron doesn't understand
at first but he quickly tries to make
Harry feel better
oh yeah that depressing then he reveals
he bought hairy ass Nico scope to help
keep an eye on serious spin Ron doesn't
have a lot of money
his family's poverty is discussed a lot
but he spent good money on his best
friend to try and help him Ron Weasley
is the type of friend we all need in
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire we
learned that there are other wizarding
schools Hogwarts is hosting the
Triwizard Tournament students from
durmstrang and beauxbatons visit for the
school year in the books they all do
something to show off their school pride
this scene is downplayed a bit in the
movie and Hogwarts doesn't get a chance
to show off their pride but you might
not know that another scene was filmed
Dumbledore leads all the Hogwarts
students in singing the school song fan
to the books know that the school song
is sung every year at the first Day
feast they also know that there is no
set tune to the song you just sing the
words however you want this cut movie
scene is hilarious the song sounds like
a train wreck
Victor Chrome's face is priceless plus
we get to see Draco Malfoy totally
appalled by Crabbe singing voice we
can't believe such a funny scene was cut
Snape on chaperon duty this next scene
is also from Goblet of Fire imagine for
a minute that you are teenager and Snape
is one of your teachers and he catches
you with your boyfriend or girlfriend
that would be mortifying during the Yule
Ball Professor Snape is on chaperon duty
he is making sure that all the teenagers
aren't doing anything inappropriate he
catches a few of them who have hidden
away in carriages and it's pretty
hilarious but it's also an important
scene
Harry's see Snape being confronted by
Igor Karkaroff the headmaster of
durmstrang Karkaroff is scared of
something and wants to know if Snape has
noticed the same thing he demands to see
Snape's forearm rolling off his feet but
Snape refuses it's pretty clear that
they are talking about the dark mark
Snape also tells
I have nothing to be scared of you go
and you say the same when they cut this
scene we don't find out about the depth
of these two men's shared history it's a
really important scene for setting up
the friend-or-foe mystery surrounding
Snape which scene would have made the
final battle so much better keep
watching to find out Dolores Umbridge
is probably the single most hated
character in the entire Harry Potter
fandom she's even worse than Voldemort
in a lot of ways
Umbridge is the Defense Against the Dark
Arts professor in order of the Phoenix
she refuses to put magic into practice
and tries to convince everyone that
Harry is lying about Voldemort's return
she uses harsh discipline methods and
even kicks out Dumbledore before she
gets carried off by centaurs Hermione
leads her and Harry to the Forbidden
Forest she lies to get Umbridge away
from the castle Umbridge is a mess she
admits why is she teaching them but then
she delivers a monologue that shows just
how messed up she is she truly believes
that she is somehow doing the right
thing and that makes her extra
terrifying thankfully Umbridge gets what
she deserves
no one could blame me we lose many
characters in the Harry Potter series
but one of the most tragic losses is
Dumbledore before Snape cast Avada
Kedavra on the top of the Astronomy
tower Dumbledore and Harry were on a
mission
they were looking for one of the
Horcruxes Dumbledore had to drink a
poison that made him hallucinate
horrible things it left him extremely
weak that whole scene was hard to watch
it got even more upsetting after he
finished the poison the real Horcrux
wasn't there Harry has to help
Dumbledore walk because he's so weak he
reassures his professor and says not to
worry because they are almost there
Dumbledore says that is just so sad in
another cutscene Harry says look they
both count on each other for support
that's a huge emotional burden for him
then he has to watch Dumbledore take the
curse and fall you meant a great deal to
him not a waste of space the Dursleys
are terrible people they tormented Harry
through his entire childhood Dudley was
always a bullet - he learned it from his
parents but in order of the Phoenix
Harry saves Dudley from the Dementors in
Deathly Hallows Part 1 Harry says
goodbye to the Dursleys they have to
leave so that Voldemort won't come after
them Vernon is happy to say farewell to
Harry but Dudley is clearly worried
about his cousin he wants to know why
Harry isn't coming Harry says besides
I'm just wasting space isn't that right
on it which is what his uncle called him
Dudley comes up and shakes Harry's hand
he says I don't think you know how I
used his face this shows so much
character growth on Dudley's part it was
sweet and so emotional it really touches
Harry he says see a big date which was
Dudley's nickname we were devastated
that this scene was cut from the final
movie understand
Draco Malfoy is a bully through most of
the movies
in the sixth film we start seeing how
tormented he is he was forced to become
a Death Eater to make amends for his
father and he really is just a kid Draco
and his cronies go after Harry Ron and
Hermione during the final battle but a
fiend fire curse starts to burn the Room
of Requirement Harry goes back with his
broom to save Draco when everyone thinks
Harry has passed away
Voldemort calls draco back to stand on
the Death Eaters side but then Harry
rolls out of Hagrid's arms a cut scene
shows Draco switching sides piell's
and runs toward Harry he tosses him his
wand so that he can defeat the Dark Lord
ultimately the scene didn't make it into
the final cut but many fans accept this
scene as Cannon and it's often mentioned
in fan fiction plenty of people wanted
to see Draco do the right thing which
scene do you wish had made it into the
movies let us know in the comments
thanks for watching don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to the things
see you next time